tonight it's mad bum all the bounds the
lefty madison bumgarner
still looking for the form that looks so
encouraging in his final two starts of
last year bob
many many good years in the major
leagues and i'm sure he laid an egg a
few times in those good years as well
you just hope those first two starts of
the year are not an indication of what
he's going to be like all season so
kanna loreano lowry the first three
hitters in this a's lineup canada 282
couple of home runs he turns delivers
and the 3-2 fish to cannas swung on and
driven to left field down the line in
the corner that is going to get down
that's a base set ken is around first
he's going to cruise into second with
the stand up double and that's the way
our ball game begins as canna stays hot
and that'll bring up lauriana who's
batting at 296. there's a swing of the
mission bumgar's got a big strikeout
that's a big first down without that of
broader advancement run away
got him with the curveball a little bit
more break than a slider's cutter
holding a third after a steal as canna
here's the fish to jed batting right to
pitch let's hit on the ground nice job
by lowry it's picked up by van meter and
the a's get an early run and can a
stolen base a big part of that so it's
one nothing athletics one of the keys
avoid three ball counts
swinging a miss on the curve ball there
it was
two strikeouts in the beginning but
oakland strikes first chris bassett with
his third start of the season the
opening night starter for the athletics
his first ever 0-2 the 2-2 pitch to la
castro leading off with a breaking ball
that's going to be trouble watch chapman
bare hands and he throws and he throws
it wild
and le castro has to well he's got to
get back to first now he's running all
over the place
the castro is going the pitch is
upstairs ball before he walked him
and the diebacks got their first two out
on an infield hitting the walk to start
the bottom of the first inning trailing
one nothing so two and two with david
peralta left-handed hitter waiting in
the on-deck circle
and a big breaking ball and cabrera
strikes out
couldn't lay off that big overhand curve
here's david peralta long time
diamondback bounced right to second and
there is a double play
chapman goes the other way and he's got
a lead off him line drive the other way
for chapman these to have their second
hit that'll bring up murphy
but it's a start that one is smoke left
center field that'll get down for hit
chapman with his great speed round
second he'll go to third burpee's gonna
try for two and he will be safe and the
asm runner is at second and third and
these have things set up with nobody out
for piscotti the pitch is a line drive
that's caught by ahmed back to second
and they got him double play what a play
by nick to get to scotty 106 miles an
hour off the bat this line drive to the
left side nick didn't really even have a
chance to gather and make a leap just
had to kind of flat foot and jump up in
the air
right up into webbing of the glove
quickly spins and throws back to second
base
bottom of the second and we'll see how
bassett ferris here vin goes to work on
van meter who's batting at 286.
and the good curveball from bassett van
meter was all tied up
and that's the second strikeout no way
and that'll bring up nick ahmed who's
batting at 286.
staying with that breaking ball and
that's a good inning for bassett couple
of strikeouts 3-2 pitch and bamboo deals
up and away not even close and that's
ball four encounters aboard for the
second time tonight now ramon he struck
you out his first time swinging a roller
left side off the glove of escobar
trickles into left field and that's
gonna move ken up to second base makes a
wide turn and holds and bumgarner just
shakes his head very little going his
way he's trailing one nothing and the
a's putting pressure on him again and
here comes lowry bumgarner's pitch swung
on pulled the third a fair ball by
escobar down the line here comes can
around third he will score l'oreal
racing to third base and he's coming
around home the throw of the plate not
nearly in time he scores standing up the
ball gets away from steven vote lowry
gets all the way to third base and he'll
stand in there yeah lowry drives in two
and it's three nothing put an error on
the board so e5 on escobar but the runs
still count
and there's ball four second walk issued
by basic
pitch to la castro coming
and that's ball four he walks two on
here comes calhoun as a tying run this
game could get real interesting real
quick with one swing of cole calhouns
back
nobody's home
here comes madison bungard le castro
will stop at third it's an rbi single
for cole calhoun
d backs on the board first in third
still only one out four is jubal cabrera
center field l'oreal got to be careful
he can really sling it no chance to get
loco and it's 3-2
right there with a fastball and he rings
up for
crack out scotty four for madison boyd
scotty knew it right away he might have
been looking for that slow curve ball
instead mad bum just pounds one in there
at the bottom of the strike zone at 90
to get the called strike three yeah all
right whatever let me know when it's my
turn
center field for la castro
and that's five in a row retired by
bumgarner two outs of the fourth
three two oakland two outs in the ending
here's the three-two pitch
and he bunted at it missed it in the
strikeout well in the ending five
strikeouts for bumgarner he's in order
jets bounced out
and double he's batting right here's the
one suit pitch and that's swung on my
jet and lying to the center field that's
going to get down for a hit over to
field the ball is le castro loriano at
second he's going to hold there
lorianno goes bumgarner spins around and
he throws it away laureato's going to
trot home
lowry's going to go from first and he's
going to go all the way to third and the
a's lead it four to two big spot for
olsen
trying to make contact right here
give the a's a three run lead and
bumgarner throws in his swing on and
that'll get the job done lifted to left
center it's playable going over making
the catches peralta lowry tags from
third and scorers and the a's take a 5-2
lead on a sac fight to left center by
olson
first pitch to chapman and he hits one
high and deep to left field and
that baby's goal
and the athletics have taken a six to
two lead chaplains jumps on the first
pitch it's a three-run fifth inning for
the a's on chapman's second long ball
this year no doubters rain making
perfect kind of a spinner that just hung
up there and chapman just
smoked it
van meter to leave things off here in
the six
2-1 pitch is ripped and
skips by olson into right field and van
meter's going to at least get two
biscotti has it hang up van meter's not
going to stop at second here he comes
over to third he'll get in safely
sliding with a triple
nick ahmed is the hitter now nico for
two
this will get van meter home
every hour for ahmed make it a 6-3 ball
game
gold gallow walking an rbi single and
calhoun did he beat the shift he did
between lowry and andrews into right
center field for a two out single
keeping it on the ground is a good thing
and here comes cabrera here's the first
pitch and there's a drive into right
biscotti on the run can't get it to get
spied to the wall
and that is going to score a run i
believe turning third into the plate is
cole calhoun the throw is not in time he
scores on an rbi double by cabrera and
it's a six to four ball game d-bags get
the timing run up there it's david
peralta
and a base hit center field here comes a
run around third laureano charges he
will fire toward the plate it'll be cut
off at 6'5 on an rbi single by peralta
here come the d-backs
with a one-out double and he's trying to
add on
and there is a hit
could have a play at the plate ball's
picked up by calhoun and the throw is
there and the slide and no he's safe
yeah biscotti looked like he just got in
between the legs of stephen vogt with
his slide and it's seven to five here's
the 1-1 pitch and that's swung on by
chapman a fly ball right field angle
toward the line a long run it's going to
drop in front of calhoun for a hit and
here's lowry around third to score
easily and these take an 8-5 lead
that one headed for the corner it is a
fair ball rattles around in the corner
here comes chapman and there will be no
throw it's an rbi double for murphy and
it's nine to five
[Applause]
here's the 1-1 pitch swung on by cabrera
ground ball to the right side in the
shift up with it elvis anders throws to
first for the out and that's three wins
in a row for the a's and for their last
five as they take the first game in this
brief series against the diamondbacks
and win it by the final of nine to five